I hear things you know what they call
stuff like that gifts where by day
vigilante by night how does that work
sometimes you have to do things outside
of the law I don't see the city anymore
all I see are dark corners house kitchen
he just died before a 2d reborn you
believe in the devil father another
man's evil does not make you a good item
mad since the day we met
I have to be the man the city needs I
respect their conviction the long man
thinks he can make a difference make my
city a better place thought why do I
still feel guilty guilt can be a good
thing
it's a Souls call to action
the indication that your work is not yet
finished
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so it's
official now daredevil season 2 going to
drop on the 18th they they officially
dodged the Batman V Superman bullet
everyone was kind of holding their
breath wondering like are they actually
gonna drop this on the same day
I feel like this teaser trailer is for
everybody that did not watch daredevil
season 1 isn't a huge daredevil fan or
only watch part of it if you ever watch
the opening title sequence for a lot of
the Marvel movies what they'll do is is
they have like the Motionflow
Marvel logo where they have the comics
in the background if it's a sequel it'll
flip through a bunch of pages that
depict all the movies that came before
it like in the case of the Avengers
movie they did it with the Sam Raimi
spider-man movies so really they're just
trying to plant the seed and the reason
why they dropped it right now is because
the TCA is the Television Critics
Association is having their big meeting
right now
daredevil technically a TV show so the
Netflix does a TC A's presentation they
also released the official synopsis for
the entire season so here you go just
when Matt thinks that he's bringing
order back to the city new forces are
rising in Hell's Kitchen now The Man
Without Fear must take on a new
adversary in Frank Castle and face an
old flame Elektra not Jos remember back
to daredevil season one foggy talked
about one of Matt's old girlfriends
bigger problems emerge when Frank Castle
a man looking for vengeance is reborn as
The Punisher a man who takes justice
into his own hands in Matt's
neighborhood which is Hell's Kitchen
meanwhile Matt must balance his duty to
his community as a lawyer and his
dangerous life as the devil of Hell's
Kitchen facing a life altering choice
that forces him to truly understand what
it means to be a hero what it sounds
like to me is he's going to be presented
with an unwinnable scenario and will
have to choose whether or not to go
super dark to solve the problem and
while this is a daredevil season it's
mostly gonna follow his character this
is all about the birth of the Punisher
so I think we'll get to see an origin
story of sorts but I'm expecting them to
do the season one thing where they
introduced the kingpin like when we meet
Frank Castle he's already doing Punisher
type things he might not be using the
name but he's already on his quest for
vengeance and then we kind of flashback
and see how it started The Punisher is a
pretty easy sell you've at least seen
one of his movies so you pretty much you
get the character figuring out what's
going on with Elektra I think is going
to be a little bit more
interesting Evo even though the Punisher
is a character is probably to be much
more badass but in the comics originally
Matt Murdock was dating Elektra in
college before either one of them had
taken up their Mantle's later Elektra
after she's become Elektra is hired by
the kingpin to kill foggy Nelson that
was the art where Elektra ended up
getting killed by bullseye then like
drugged herself to Matt Murdock's
apartment and died in his arms she was
resurrected later in the comics and came
back but that was a long time ago since
then there's been a bunch of different
stories where she's worked with
daredevil
she's a lot more ambiguous than
daredevil or punished are like Punisher
is just openly hardcore I'm gonna kill
any villain I get my hands on Elektra is
an assassin for hire so she exists in
this moral gray area so that's kind of
how I'm expecting the TV show to treat
her like oh hey Matt yeah we used to
have sex in college how awesome to see
you again oh by the way I'm an assassin
for hire now and I'm gonna be killing
somebody that you might know I am gonna
get really excited if there's like a
phone call scene from prison from the
kingpin early in this series where he's
like I are the woman to take care of the
problem and all sudden you see it shoot
to Elektra showing up in the city when
they talk about a dangerous new force
rising in the city I'm wondering if it's
going to be the hand that would be like
the next logical place to go because he
killed Nobu during season one Nobu was
one of the leaders of the hand it would
make sense that they would retaliate in
some way and then there's the black sky
plant like they wanted that special
block of the city for Supernatural
reasons probably so even though
daredevil is this crime drama show I'm
really hoping they push into more
mystical things because we have to get
to Iron Fist eventually and it makes
sense that they would try to tease the
idea of mysticism in the universe so
what I'm expecting is is the season two
is gonna be all about the origin of the
Punisher and Elektra and the chased in
the hand so let me know in the comments
what do you guys think the new force
this rising in Hell's Kitchen is going
to be like this mysterious dangerous
force that's going to push daredevil to
have to make the decision whether or not
to start being like the Punisher and
start killing people or stay true to his
beliefs I know a lot of you aren't
digging his costume I think they could
tweak it a little bit I'm not expecting
them to change it too much I think the
thing you really need to get excited for
is to see the Punisher
start wearing the skull t-shirt in from
the looks of him in these pictures he's
not going to be wearing full-on military
gear for a while maybe by the end of the
series now the other really big
you guys may have seen me talking about
on Twitter this morning was the Teen
Titans TV show
TNT confirmed that it is dead in the
water meaning that all the characters
that they were going to use are now free
for other people to use which means a
lot of things so I'm gonna be doing a
Teen Titans video tonight be sure to
subscribe to get that I've already done
a whole bunch of daredevil videos about
Electress character about the Punisher
but if there are any others that you
guys want me to do just let me know in
the comments what's gonna happen with my
daredevil videos whenever whenever that
series drops is it'll be just like
jessica jones where i'll do pretty
pretty much all the videos that i'm
gonna do for it within about a 10 day
period it seemed that the vast majority
of you guys had watched jessica jones
within the first two weeks of the show i
still run into people that haven't
watched jessica jones yet which i'm kind
of surprised by but usually those are
people that are just a little bit more
casual with stuff like that usually
everyone who's a big Marvel fan or a big
comic book fan will watch it right away
in case you missed it or you haven't
seen it in a while you can click here
for my Electra do just talking a little
bit about her origin story and you can
click here to learn all about king shark
coming back to the flash season 2 it's
gonna be another arrow crossover episode
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you